everybody that follows me knows that all
my comedy comes from a real place I'm
alive I'm still experiencing [ __ ] which
still means I have stuff to talk about
let's go make these people laugh this is
the payoff
we saw the football stadium on tonight
I'll stop it stop trying to make me feel
at all
cause you know grandma grandma send over
to my I'm not giving you my money this
is gonna pay for my global tour huh you
just say messed up here on ice you wanna
explain yourself Kevin I'm Halle Berry I
don't get messed up that's a bunch of
Halle [ __ ] private school kids don't
have any edge you need edge to surviving
life my son definitely doesn't have I
got some of my friends over my house
that I grew up with
we're having a thug like conversation I
hear my son coming down the steps
I hear flip-flops popping they pop it
fast
something's wrong dad Wi-Fi is down I
don't know what made me more upset that
oh my friend going who's Wi-Fi will you
look around this room tonight I see
every race ethnicity nationality
possible I see some everybody
the bear if you can laugh together you
can live together you can love together
what now people
hey keV it's on you
so like bet check fold well aware of the
poker rules mr. tuna is using something
punch you in the face I'm gonna make all
of that bleed my name is done cheating
I'm mad because I'm that Iron Man I'm
the black eyed man and I'm rusty that's
uncalled for
I'm a squeak when I go be the first
order advance tickets now at vending go
calm and it's go suits
the obsessive personality
can our son lead a normal life